así como otros países europeos el reino
unido continúa con su misión diplomática
para lograr disuadir a rusia ante una
posible invasión de ucrania en una
jornada maratónica el primer ministro
boris johnson viajó a bruselas a la sede
de la otan desde donde advirtió que esta
es la mayor crisis de seguridad a la que
se ha enfrentado europa en décadas
johnson dijo que si rusia invadió
ucrania sería un error catastrófico
porque los ucranianos responderán y
entonces habría un baño de sangre horas
después johnson viajó a polonia donde
con el presidente de ese país cerraron
filas en torno a un solo mensaje la
salida de esta creciente tensión entre
rusia y occidente debe ser negociada y
rusia no puede invadir ucrania con ese
mismo objetivo la ministra de exteriores
británica liz tras quien se encuentra en
moscú se reunió con su similar ruso para
tratar de avanzar en esta salida
negociada esa misión no se cumplió por
el contrario hubo intercambio de
reproches entre las partes fue tal la
atención en ese encuentro que el
canciller ruso sérguei lávrov dijo que
esta fue una conversación entre un mudo
y un sordo entretanto el gobierno
británico presentó en el parlamento hoy
lo que será una ley para sancionar a
quienes tengan vínculos cercanos con el
kremlin